welcome Mr Prime Minister on Thursday
U.S President Joe Biden welcomed Indian
Prime Minister Narendra Modi to the
White House for a joint press conference
and to strike deals on security trade
and immigration the U.S is eager to turn
India into an ally that can help check
China's influence in the indo-pacific
today the partnership between our
countries is stronger than it's ever
been welcome to prime minister modi's
Washington home however critics say
setting out the Good China and Crystal
for Modi is essentially rewarding him
for violating his citizens human rights
in 2002 riots broke out in the Indian
state of Gujarat Modi chief minister of
Gujarat at the time was accused of
stoking the violence he was later
cleared
still Washington denied Modi a visa to
the U.S for nearly 10 years reinstating
it only after he was elected prime
minister in 2014.
human rights activists say modi's
government has either targeted or failed
to protect Muslims Sikhs Christians from
religious-based violence
allegations Modi denied
they have always proved that our
democracy can deliver and when I say
deliver this is regardless of caste
Creed religion or gender there is
absolutely no space for discrimination
even so modi's invitation to address
Congress Drew objections from a few
legislators including Michigan
representative Rashida Talib we urge all
members of Congress who profess to stand
for human rights freedom and democracy
to join us in boycotting modi's joint
address to Congress cheers the calls to
ignore Modi largely brushed off by
official Washington eager to keep India
on its side in global Affairs Russell
and Jordan Al Jazeera Washington